is there
uh an optimal temperature for sleep
that i i should mention i think your
latest episode
uh you uh and people should go check out
helixsleep.com huberman to support
andrew
uh thanks for the plug
i mean that's the amazing thing about
the stuff they're creating oh
and yes you have a new podcast that's
amazing and this past month he did a
whole series on sleep
which uh people should definitely check
out there's some podcasts that come out
that just make me want to be a better
human being
by just the quality uh three blue one
brown grant
sanderson is like that for me just like
wow
this is uh education is best so andrew
uh symbolizes that captures that
brilliantly so go support the sponsor so
he doesn't stop doing the thing
uh so they i think they have a cooling
pad too
so i ate sleep mattress sponsors me
uh they've been they sent me a mattress
and it's been i've never listened i used
to sleep
on the floor sleeping before you fall
you sleep before i fall i don't give a
it doesn't doesn't really matter but so
like i would have never
bought a nice mattress because it's like
why
i'm fine this is a floor it's fine but
it was a game changer to uh be able to
control temperature like for me it's
cooling
to cool i don't know what the hell it is
well you want the brain and nervous
system
and the rest of the body needs to drop
by about anywhere from two to three
degrees in order to get into your
deepest sleep and transition to sleep
that's really going to help you don't
want to be cold that you're
bothered and can't fall asleep but
that's why some people like it really
cold in the room and under a warm
blanket or with socks on for some people
that can that can be good because this
temperature oscillation
is such that as your temperature is
dropping that correlates with the
generally with the most sleepy phase of
your circadian cycle
so cool is better for falling and
staying asleep and sleeping deeply
and then i i guess like that's what ate
sleep showed they have like an app
is uh it warms back up uh to wake you up
the idea that
i haven't actually used it i'm like this
is stupid uh
people say it works but i just keep it
the same temperature throughout the
night
but uh warming it up i guess wakes you
up which is
it was just fascinating yeah because
your the wake up signal
is it's interesting to think about it's
not just correlated with an increase in
body temperature the increase in body
temperature
is triggering the release of cortisol
from your adrenals and that's the wake
up signal
do you think it's absolute temperatures
we're talking about is just even
relative
just even just a decrease well
everyone's going to have slightly
different
basal temperature the idea that
everybody should be 98.6 i mean that's a
myth
and there are theories that body
temperature overall has been dropping in
the last 50 years or so i i doubt that's
true for somebody who's athletic like
you and is
you know young and healthy but basically
the the coldest period of that 24-hour
cycle
is when you are going to be sleepiest
there's actually a period within that
24-hour cycle
it's a it's a time point called your
temperature minimum and your temperature
minimum tends to be
about two hours before your typical
wake-up time
i'm not talking about the wake-up time
in the middle of the night where you go
use the bathroom or where you set an
alarm to go catch a flight i mean
if you were to just allow yourself to
sleep without a clock for a few days
measure when you typically wake up two
hours before then is your temperature
minimum
and that temperature minimum turns out
to be a very important
landmark in your circadian cycle because
it turns out that if you get bright
light in your eyes
in the hours immediately before your
temperature minimum
so two to four hours or any time within
the two or four hour window before that
temperature minimum
you are going to what's called delay
your circadian clock the next day
that whole oscillation is going to move
forward it will make you want to go to
sleep later
and wake up later whereas if you get
bright light in your eyes in the
hours after that temperature minimum so
let's say for me
typical wake up time is 6 a.m my
temperature minimum somewhere around 4
a.m if i get bright light in my eyes
5 a.m 6 a.m 7 a.m it's going to advance
that oscillation so that i want to go to
bed earlier
and wake up earlier the subsequent
nights so you might say
wait but most nights i go to sleep and
wake up at more or less the same time
why is that
and that's because the same thing is
happening on both sides you are both
advancing your clock a little bit
and assuming that you're looking at
light in the evening you're also
delaying your clock a little bit so you
get kind of captured in between and then
your rhythm more or less oscillates
at the at the same period as we say as
the
spin of the earth unless you're like you
where you're at i get text messages from
you sometimes at
odd hours and i'm i if you're on the
east coast then i know that you had to
have been
pulling basically an all night yeah yeah
you